This symbol first showed up in the 1770s,
appearing in documents of English-Americans
who had business dealings with Spanish-Americans.
However, it wasn’t until the very early
1800s that it became popularized, around the
same time as the first official U.S. dollars
were being minted.
Previous to this, the symbol had already been
in use as an abbreviation for names of Spanish
currency, namely as an abbreviation for the
Spanish peso “p”.
So how do you get from a “p” to the dollar
sign, “$”? When writing financial documents
referring to pesos, it was common to abbreviate
the peso, for instance, “1 peso” to “1
p”.
However, when pluralized, as in “1000 pesos”,
it becomes “ps“.
When writing up financial documents and having
to write “ps” numerous times, it started
to become common among the English-American
colonists to merge the “p” and the super
scripted “s” as one.
The top half of this symbol then produces
something looking very much like a double
vertical lined dollar sign.
In an even further bout of laziness, it became
common among the English-American colonists
to write the “p” with just one downward
stroke vertically slashing the “s”, thus
the ‘$’. In some of the earliest documents
containing this short hand, it was common
to see both the double slashed version as
well as the single slashed version in the
same document, referring to the same thing,
the Spanish peso.
How then did this symbol that originally denoted
pesos spread to also denote the U.S. dollar?
Around the same time the U.S. was minting
its first dollar coins, in 1792, Spanish currency
was extensively circulated in the U.S. and
around the world.
In large part due to this, the U.S. chose
to design the U.S. dollar coins to duplicate
the Spanish coins, in terms of matching the
material and weight, hence value (at the time,
the coins were made of silver and valued after
the price of silver).
Doing this allowed the U.S. coin to be exchanged
for a peso in a 1 to 1 exchange.
Thus, it was natural to use the same symbol
to denote the U.S. dollar as was used for
the Spanish peso.